so now we're going up but pronouncing it
would mean the opponent
that's not that easy
so it's english
yes that's a well-known
idea special position is hindu a bit
unusual again comes that a
little earlier
any attempts to hold the pawns
are usually too dangerous
but you can really  easy here too
it doesn't change too
badly I can't really
believe in it but well
thought he just takes her back
so easy to seven but that's with her
five
plays may not be so stupid
okay
I can take and then six
game runs  it wasn't planned with an attack on so and
so but maybe the
culprit access
there was four maybe
five queens b
58 and then for example six
hung e5 and b7 threatens
well
that could actually work
and i have to take
what i take
it actually comes to this one
strange variant
so what is that now for a
position here
maybe so c6
you would have to  i still get the
pawn or
difficult
with it bifie or something else
actually plays to beat
now i get the pawn
so at the end of the whole action he
now has to do and
get
pawn so the sticking point now is actually
how fast do i get it all in
the gears the three very key
move I have to do it right away so
that I can get all the figures active
then maybe I
should have done it now instead of taking a
7 I can still
do that
well but how it was I was a
a bit fast
at least not totally hip
he can't
really prefer the farmers at the moment i think it's
really
ok
sometimes i'm just
like that and now at b 7
it really depends very often just
like that i have him then i can
beat
it two there  are on the usual series I have
to be careful that something doesn't make
sense to me again at some point
okay but I can take it first
I said I have to a
watch out for the red 3s thoma 1
then i have to at least somehow
ok there not done
so what kind of position is that now
can he could withdraw and
then exchange everything
i can cover you 7 year not so good
jumper your 5 is still possible  with the
between
I made them here
and now runs
up to 2
that's critical are the
next few moves now that
material isn't somehow
lost here that can easily
happen
runner c5 for example somehow
that then the parts are a bit
reasonable  can think
so maybe first os 6
they are totally down to five
maybe running 7
now do running here
so nothing was lost
so we can try to do something
against f 2
can i take
i hope that the thunderstorm will come
with the
easy figure constellation
well maybe it's not enough maybe
yes
check
we have two builds fortunately it
really is  just
well
somehow quite plausible except where I
didn't see the opening coming but how did it
go 96 you probably even
good for black